you
[Music]
I thank you for the introduction hi
everyone tell me if you don't hear me
enough I'm J M I'm data engineer and
leaders of internal analytics team a
data dog in our team that our job is to
provide data to the rest of the other
teams at the company and for this we had
to be a pipeline that has to be always
modular scaleable and observable to
build a strong internal analytics
platform and to do so we adopted a
specific approach that we call ETTL and
that's what I'm going to present today
so we'll see a little bit of context so
what we do and how why ETL what were the
challenges that we had to face that we
have to face every day and that we try
to solve with this approach hopefully
there are some challenges that we share
and that you are facing also in your day
to day work how this design helps us
solving them how we make sure that it
keeps solving them over time thanks to
monitoring so what we do and how quick
introduction of what it does ring we do
these rivets before we are monitoring
platform for cloud scale infrastructure
and application where gates from more
than 250 technologies for
troubleshooting
alerting graphing we ingest trillions of
data points per day through performance
metrics traces request through your
systems here logs also when you can
correlate all that on one unique
platform and then you can set up some
pretty advanced alerting on top of it so
that's for the project to digital
product what my team does is our mission
is to provide all the other teams
attitude dog with data and analytics to
have them answer questions about the
product usage business and the
operations
the team is composed of data engineers
that are going to take care of the data
pipeline and the data is going to be
produced
well the designer is not going to use
them to build Analytics report for the
rest of the company that's the tools
from which we ingest data which is for
more than 40 data sources right now you
might recognize a few logos here from
internal databases where other
engineering team usually provide us with
data extracts also marketing tools sales
tools and discovery is growing there are
more and more teams more and more tool
that I use a data dog so this pool of
data is always growing we have always to
set up new integration with new tools
and on the other side of the pipeline
once we ingest all that the output that
we produce has information about the
usage of our product and features by our
users the traffic on our application and
the different websites that we own sign
up attribution which is really
interesting for marketing what brings
sign up what inference people to sign up
for day to dog same thing for revenue
and then we can get performance of
marketing efforts thanks to that also
the state of the sales pipeline and
finally data about the cost of our cloud
infrastructure so how we do this how do
we provide this data well from the data
source we have a daily pipeline that
runs every night this pipeline contains
workers Luigi and spark I'm going to
talk a little bit more about Adam Adam
in detail after Luigi is going to work
on the etre machine cc2 and spark as you
may know is running on EMI elastic
MapReduce clusters which are a bunch of
hissy two instances actually we have a
pretty neat - a platform that we use at
all the data engineering teams of the
drug use to manage these ecosystems is
going to run the rigid jobs and spark
jobs on the VMS
spinning up the EMR clusters whence spot
Robbie is launched
for data storage we use inside this
pipeline as for all the intermediary
steps s3 but the output of all that is
going to be loaded to a data warehouse
which is redshift which is fully managed
data warehouse which is great for
working with huge datasets and on top of
redshift we plugged a visualization tool
which is looker you might know it's also
once we have this output in the data
warehouse how do all the teams access
this data well first of all of course
through looker they can consume the
report that our team is building for
them and that we maintain they can also
dig into the data themself
people with sequel skiers they can
directly run sequel queries against the
redshift data warehouse we also working
on pushing data to other systems like
Salesforce and ESCO Marketo finally
something interesting is that not only
we produce data analytics reporting but
all the teams especially engineering
teams can also use our data directly
from s3 to create new features on the
data products itself which is pretty
cool and that's because the structure of
our pipeline that I'm going to present
creates a very nice interface with our
data at different stages of his
transformation all right now you get all
the context you need so ye TTL what are
the challenges and requirements that we
had to face and that we had to tackle
you might recognize a few of them and we
might share the same challenges well
first of all our data sources are highly
diverse in their formats in the type of
data to ingest from there are always
evolving and there is a constant need we
get a ton of requests to add a new data
source every week then working with data
backfilling is really important as you
know so it has to be very easy to do
we are aiming for long-term persistence
then as a company is growing there are
different levels of sensitivity in the
data and in the permissioning that
different people has to access this data
finally the pipeline and the data itself
has to be reliable and robust and facing
these challenges with the traditional
approach of ETL what can become a
nightmare first of all the data sources
that are always evolving means that
every time you need to change and tweak
the whole pipeline there is a lot of
residence - changes in the data source
itself if your systems doesn't have a
versioning and the data there is always
evolving well if you don't extract it
every day you cannot go back in time and
say show me the size of the data a year
ago then cleaning a transformation can
be duplicated a parameter is function
can live in a giant utyos' file if one
has fail the whole pipeline is going to
fail and back then you can take forever
then managing the dependencies between
the different tasks can be a nightmare
and that our data ops can be very
complex so we came up with a new
approach that we call ET GL so what do I
mean by that so the TT is for chair
transform step so a traditional approach
of ETL is extracting do a bunch of
transformation with a transform step and
then load the output to your data
warehouse
well here the transform step is going to
be segmented into three tiers so from
the data source we're going to have a
first share which is prone
then the second one that we call silver
and the last one you can guess it's
going to be gold and then the output is
going to be loaded into the data
warehouse so what's going to happen here
is that we are going to persist data a
virus point points in the pipeline and
that's going to allow us to tackle the
different challenges that are presented
by before so what a bronze silver and
gold bronze
we're going to simply extract from the
data source and put the data in a land
that we control that we own
what's happening there so we're going to
extract it and put it in the bronze s3
bucket here we're going to simply bring
the site of all the different tools all
the different systems in one place and
again it's a raw extract so no
transformation is happening
no renaming no filtering and the data is
going to end up in bronze in a structure
tabular format so we extract once and
then the coping with that is that we
don't care what's happening after in the
source because we have the data
processor in to persist it and we can
always go back to this layer and read
back with everything from it if
something goes wrong downstream is a
pipeline concrete example if you have
this in your data source in bronze no
transformations going to be exactly the
same in the bronze s3 bucket then silver
silver between bronze and silver is
going to be a one-to-one mapping between
the objects so each object in bronze
that we extracted from a data source is
going to have its corresponding objects
in silver what's happening in silver
we're going to keep on is the column
that we need to work with after we're
going to rename them with four different
names and class to the right type we're
going to take care also of the scheme
evolutions of the column changing so for
example you have starting from these
dates this column is appearing from
these other dates this chrome actually
changed his name so we are taking care
of all this evolution from bronze to
silver and here we are going to apply
all the shared grooming and this is
going to happen in massive parallel
because this cleaning is going to
between all the objects between bronze
and silver is going to happen at the
same time
so that's highly efficient and fast what
I mean by shared grooming is that we're
going to apply all the features of the
filters to data cleaning and the simple
rollover operation or duping also that
needs to happen before the data is ready
to be used
downstream in the pipeline and each
objects in silver actually is likely to
be used by multiple tiles downstream so
this cleaning
here's a
only once and then we will use the
object concrete example we had this in
bronze in silver we're going to have
cash casting to the right tab it's an
integer giving grid even naming applying
world level simple world level
transformations the time step are going
to end up in the right format and so on
then called again we are going to load
into the s3 buckets as dedicated to cold
so here gold is the analytics layer
that's where we're going to implement
all the business logic and since these
transformations are pretty heavy that's
what we're going to use puck here the
output is going to be the final objects
that will then be loaded into the data
warehouse concrete example again you had
different objects in silver yeah we're
going to do all the heavy lifting that
joins the big business logic and for
example were going to create the new
columns that requires to implement heavy
transformations once we have our objects
that are ready to be used
we simply load them into the data
warehouse redshift something to note is
that how we are going to load into the
data warehouse is going to highly depend
on the nature of the object if your
objects is just attributes about an
entity like your customers and you care
only about the most recent state of the
data where every day were going to
simply truncate the table and reinsert
the most recent data if it's daily
activity well in that case is going to
be an insert sometimes and absurd to
avoid duplicates so recap between the
data source and the load to the data
warehouse we have three tiers
the first one is bronze that's data
gathering steps we get the data we don't
apply any transformation and then we own
this data silver that's the
normalization layer here we know that
all the objects are clean and ready to
be used
done streams I want one mapping between
bronze and silver between the objects
and finally gold that's the analytics
layer here the dependencies can be much
more complex much more complex because
right now for example our pipeline
contains 370 different tasks and each
task can have have up to 30 dependencies
so it's going to require 30 other tasks
to run before it's able to run itself so
to avoid to have a respective plate
managed manually we use Luigi but kind
of the orchestra maestro files which is
an open-source project originally
created Spotify and it's going to old
all the logic between the different
tasks and chain them together based on
the dependency graph that you're going
to create who is using widgey here okay
a few yeah quite a few people this is
the structure of a basic widget job you
can see it like a cron job but in Python
the different sections are going to be
like the parameters that you're going to
use in your job then the most important
thing is the require section that's why
you're going to say which task this
widget job or task is going to depend on
which one is going to require to run
before it's able to run then the task
logic itself and then simply where the
output is going to be written in s3 here
most of the time for us but for this
requires step rigidly framework provided
by this tool is already powerful but it
was not powerful enough for us to manage
the complex dependencies between our
different objects so we took this
powerful framework and we simply
extended it because for example let's
take these page view objects that we
have in gold you might think that it's
simply going to require the page views
of today in silver and squares bonding
object in bronze but actually is not
just this maybe we are going to enrich
it with some user information for this
we want the most recent data and then we
want to add some used project use a
j-roller
and with three days window then these
cold objects going to require another
gold object with some page categories of
today data that's going to require the
whole story of page attributes in silver
and then the corresponding bronze
objects so you can get very complex and
thanks to the abstraction that we
created by extending the framework
provided by Luigi we're able to simply
code all these very easily the exchange
the extension of this framework doesn't
stop only in the dependencies between
the tasks we also created some level of
abstraction to be able to easily add new
data sources we ingest from different
tools like I said it can be s3 for
project usage data or marketing data is
going to live maybe in Google
spreadsheet and saves my plain data in
Salesforce when we are going to have one
extract based tasks for each one of
these subjects and the inputs are going
to be simply parameters so every time we
need to add a new as3 path a new Google
Spreadsheets ID or a new series for
subjects which just reuse the same task
with different parameters you may be
wondering how we code all these how
what's our development process well in
our team each developer is going to
share the same pool of data in bronze
because that's simply the raw extract
that we work with but then starting from
silver each developer is going to have
his own mini version of the pipeline so
each developer is going to have his own
s3 folder where when it's coding on
staging is going to write to this folder
for each person then same thing called
and also even we want to be able to test
a full pipeline so even when loading to
the data warehouse each developer is
going to have is own version of the
tables that way we are able to work the
whole pipeline
test everything properly and once it's
ready for
primetime we just merge it into the pod
by plane and while developing we work
with small datasets which allows us to
work with smaller clusters which is
cost-efficient
alright so you know what the ETTL design
looks like but how does it solve the
challenges that are presented in the
beginning first of all the data sources
remember there are highly diverse always
evolving and we always need to add new
ones
well like I just said we have one base
ties per day to source in bran so it's
really easy for us to add new object
that we ingest in our pipeline of course
if we need to develop a new API extract
with a new tool takes a bit more time
but it doesn't happen often and each
object that we are going to extract are
going to be completely isolated until
silver but in silver we know that they
are going to end up in formats that's
ready to be used and reused and stream
is a pipeline we take care of the
economy evolution for example then
working with data I'm sure you have two
phases often back feeding is really
important because you might realize oops
there is a bug downstream my pipeline so
I need to tweak the logic fix it and
then I need to repack feed everything
for the past few months well in the
meantime all the teams need the data so
you don't want it to take a week well
with this design of each ETL and the
different tiers you can see each tier
like a checkpoint that way if the logic
is wrong all we have to simply enrich or
tweak the logic somewhere we only need
to read back feel from the tiers that
was impacted by this change
for instance we want to add a new column
well browse we don't touch it is just
extract and then we simply have to be
back feel silver and cold if we want to
tweak the business logic bronze and
silver stay as the same and we simply
need to backfill called
and sometimes for some objects like gene
table like snapshots where you only care
about the most recent state
the data you don't even need to be back
here just tweak the logic and the next
pipeline during the next night is going
to simply take care of putting the most
recent data with the new logic then we
are aiming for a long-term persistence a
concrete example here that's a real
message that we receive in our slack
Channel last week so someone from the
State Department had an urgent need they
wanted to have an export of two
different objects from Salesforce from
December 31st 2017 here I just remove
the name and to the panda provide peek
at all we don't have a panda for now
and while we are able to do this because
even if you say it's for incest false
the data changes in this source we don't
care we have the whole story in bronze
also in silver so we can thanks to that
investigates the state the historical
state of the data at any given point in
time so here what I just needed to do is
to get the extract from December 31st
2017 in s3 and the loaded and provide it
to this team that's because the data
source is exactly the same as what we
have in bronze and apparently did the
trick that's not me who rocks that's
ETTL rocks when I rock too good that's
another story and this process is really
really important really crucial because
we can read back with everything from it
well we put some place some safeguards
and backups because also s3 is not
always perfectly reliable and speaking
of backups we have some also in the end
tables into the data warehouse because
that's the object that our end user is
going to interact with directly then the
dog is growing we have more and more
data that are more or less entity when
I'm carrying saying sensitive data you
can think about revenue costs but also
sales performance data and different
people at tech though we have different
permission to access these sensitive
data how we do with that
in s3 in the transform step of our
pipeline we have different buckets and
rolls that can be accessed through I am
and then in redshift we have different
schemas the data is going to be
segmented in different schemas in the
redshift and in lucre different
connections are going to be linked to t2
these different schemas and then there
is a permissioning in the car
finally we want our data pipeline and
the data itself to be reliable and
robust well they - doc is a monitoring
and alerting tool so we simply use our
own product first of all the data should
be fresh and means that we need to make
sure that our pipeline runs every night
we have set up some alerts if the
pipeline fails we are at it directly on
slug on Pedro duty not only we are
alerted to Eve the pipeline fails but we
set up also some preventive alerts and
is going to notify us if the data is
missing the source and properly
formatted same thing we received in the
notification and we are able to fix it
before the background fires most of the
time also we want our pipeline to fail
only when it's worth it so sometimes
it's not a big deal if the de is
improperly formatted there will be just
one tweak to apply later date
engineering team a little also monito
the latency of it like how old is your
data somewhere a lot for us in s3 that
way you know that if your pipeline
doesn't burn while the data is getting
older and older and maybe your customers
are going to be impacted so you can have
poor flat out on these - you can see
that every time the pipeline is going to
run on your job is going to run what the
age of the data is going to come back to
zero then there should be fresh but not
only it needs to be accessible so we
monitor our own infrastructure redshift
and Luke are mainly because that's the
two main tool that people are going to
interact with to get access to the data
same thing we have a lot if some of them
are down
we have some dashboard that allows us to
correlate the performance metrics from
redshift and from the Lucar instance not
only that I should be accessible but we
don't want people to stay in front of
that computer for like 10 minutes before
dashboard loads in lucre or before
escrow query returns so the data query
should be performant to do so we want to
monitor the performance of the query
against red shift in red shifts some of
them I know but Reggie provides a
feature called workload management that
allows you to segment your query based
on some attributes like who is running
the query is it your own pipeline is it
someone via lucre and we also monitor
how much time it takes to load a
dashboard on the car
these data are not available out of the
box with just integration between data
dog and V systems so to do so we are
running custom queries against some
internal tables in these tools and then
one once we get the data from this query
we sent them as custom metrics to data
dog and then we can basically use all
the other features like on any other
performance metric which is nice is that
we can define some SLA and make sure
that we respect them example if a table
takes more than 20 seconds to be queried
well we want to tune the system all the
tables or maybe sometimes at the
redshift cluster level we don't monitor
on your stack but we want all the data
itself because the data should be always
accurate first of all we monitor how
many data we insert with our pipeline
every night and to do so we use a
feature called anomaly detection because
we want to make sure that tonight I'm
not going to insert 10 times the number
of data that I used to insert yesterday
because if if that happen I might want
to investigate what's wrong the coping
with anomaly detection is that takes
into account seasonally cheese and it's
interesting for example when I want to
insert data but
because I know that during weekends
there are less people visiting our
website or application it takes into
account also trends then just put in
accuracy in the data we want to spot
missing dates like I said now mapping
runs every day and we want to make sure
that all the objects contain all the
data for every day it's especially
useful when we pack field and we have to
repack here for like the past two years
want to make sure we didn't miss any
date so for this we have some coffee
that runs against our final object into
the data warehouse and then we are going
to send events to date to Doug and it's
going to be able to alert us if one date
is missing for one particular object
then duplicates that's a bad thing
working with data well we spoke we try
to spot the pk's first directly inside
the transform step in cold when our
spark shop runs but since poverty of
objects is just loading a subset of the
data we want also to spot the crickets
directly in the final tables in redshift
in the data warehouse same thing we have
some query that runs but the brocades
send an even today to dog and we know
exactly which objects is impacted past
deprecated how do we know which object
is impacted where we use tags because
when you send a metric or an event to
the to dog you can and reach it with
some attributes tags for example here's
our - model monitor the performance of
our queries against redshift the nice
thing with tags that we are able to
slice and dice the data based on who
which user is running the query is it
our own pipeline is it someone onlooker
which objects and you can simply toggle
the filters at the top of the dashboard
then of course we investigate logs
especially when the pipeline fails or
service and issue somewhere so we want
to know what's happening well you can
also stress and as it logs themself with
the tags that will be here on the left
and for example we about to know if the
logs just
and there are one on info that's a basic
thing but we know also which which tasks
I'm looking at which object is related
to this what date what data source and
most importantly which tier I'm looking
at again bronze silver gold or the load
to redshift so from the data source to
the data warehouse how do we make sure
that we pack all the challenges that we
have to face we have a tier transform
step with bronze silver and gold and to
make sure that it keeps solving the
different challenges that we have we set
up some powerful monitoring on top of it
is that interests you we are hiring so
you can check the job offers on the
website and simply swing by our booth or
just talk to me during our office hours
after thank you very much
[Music]
you spoke a little bit about handling
sensitive data you have an issue where
some of your gold sources have column
level sensitive fields but others are
not and if so how do you handle that
yeah in gold
since its Store the industry that will
be mainly developer accessing it for
that anytime there is sensitive data we
just put it into sensitive buckets so I
can Paul yeah like you said object
related to sales if there is one cream
that allows to know the sales
performance of a sales rep well that's
consider a sensitive data especially
that in cold there is the food
granularity because it's at the whole
object that's different when it's in
looker where you can show on the
aggregated data and not allow people to
dig into the data and see other and the
full granularity
for development environments you said
each user gets a copy of the production
data do you need to obfuscate or clean
that data before they get it no because
our develop right now to map simply
access to all the data but again usually
we don't work with the 40-story we just
work with a few days of data when coding
other questions yeah have question for
the late tier thing you have gold Brown
silver like I'm assuming that's
different staging Luigi's right yeah
exact so my question is how do you get
when you take a guarantee that how do
you make sure your Brown's data is
reliable if there is no out of order or
like delayed data's when you try to
generate silver or gold data well in
bronze indeed that's exactly what's in
the data saw so if the data source is
inaccurate the inaccuracy will be in
bronze - but then we usually spot it in
the pipeline later and we will basically
work with the team that provides us the
data in the data source to investigate
why this accuracy was here not the type
of inaccuracies that's a one that are
created by us but our pipeline and there
are one that are just coming from the
data source and for which we cannot read
do anything besides just working with
the other team to fix them oh do you
guys have any like a monitoring system
to see if any of the raw date has
changed and any flag any maybe
invalidate any branch stage results we
don't have anything at fence for now now
we don't but usually people that consume
the data at the output of the pipeline
so people tell us like when there is
something wrong we usually know it
pretty fast
final question so with the tiered
approach obviously you have a lot of
different strongly defined data sets
with schemas do you guys do anything
special to help you manage migrations
migration to other tools for example
migration
migrations hmm not sure I understand do
you have any cooked example changing
columns changing column types that
anything yeah sure well that's we simply
have like I said we have to repack heal
from this silver tier and then the rest
of the Batman but yeah when you change a
column you want to add new ones you have
to move back feeling again but usually
in fact only one subset of the pipeline
[Music]